my YouTube superstar with nearly 5
million subscribers so people like him
Manny Gutierrez also known as Manny
MUA is a trailblazer in the world of
cosmetics y'all he's the first male
ambassador for Maybelline and his makeup
tutorials have literally been viewed
nearly 500 million times before Manny
was accepted in the world of cosmetics
he struggled to be accepted in his own
family here to share their story of love
and forgiveness as Manny Gutierrez and
his father Manny senior y'all give it up
all because this happens a lot in
families where people they don't
especially got from the south and people
don't grow up around the gay culture so
they're kind of thrown by and they don't
know how to like handle it at first and
I just love y'all so much for sharing
this story it's gonna inspire so many
people but were you always into makeup
I was actually always into makeup I
loved it I loved see my mom transform in
the morning I loved seeing her turn to
superwoman you know like she I could see
the transformation in her she felt more
confident she loved it and I was like oh
my god mom like this is like amazing and
I loved it Matt all right did you
struggle with me and his interest at
first I definitely did growing up in a
Latino household the LGBT community
discussions never happened it was it was
something new to me so I had a real hard
time understanding it and accepting it
because you didn't grow up around no I
grew up in a completely different world
exactly exactly so it was very rough
so like Ava Beauty acceptance is a big
part of your brand do you relate to this
Oh completely especially what you were
talking about like my mother is my
biggest beauty inspiration and those
memories of watching her like transform
there's a perfect word she used to work
at the Hollywood Chinese Theatre and
back in the 80s I didn't go to work with
her and she had to wear like the very
the Chinese I don't know what the
problem that gown you know with the high
collar in the red
and I would watch or we'd be on the bus
it would be like super like not elegant
except she would be this like you know
he can yeah this thing and so that that
inspired me and continues to inspire me
that image of my mother being this
goddess you know yeah my daughter thinks
I'm a goddess so I understand this got
worse as you got older though right
right so as I got older I started
succumbing to my own and I was like you
know I love this but I was scared that
my parents would not accept who I was
yeah so I hid it from them I hid it from
them as I got older and actually went to
counseling when I was little like a
little counselor moment to just be like
are you gay or not let's make you not
gay and I'm like it was a struggle for
sure but you know as I tell you
especially as a kid no this isn't right
like and this isn't in your like wait
well this is me like why are you saying
like I'm not right like what is how do
you change that and you can't change it
and so instead of changing I just like
recruited you know I was like okay I'm
gonna let my whole world my whole
fantasy offline I went to her I went I
worked at Sephora inside JCPenney cuz I
got my little JCPenney outfit when I
would I would okay I would get glammed
for work because I would do this I work
I didn't want parents to seek so so
embarrassed I got I was scared that they
were gonna say something about it
I would glad my work jump out my window
go to work come back and drive home take
off all makeup before I got in and I
walk in like hey what's up all right how
did you finally come to terms mani
senior like would your son how did that
finally start evolved I think it was a
big turning point and in my life was
when one day it was more of an argument
more than discussion with my wife we had
an argument because I was having a hard
time she was and she was a mama bear and
that's what she does she was protecting
her son and she told me and I remember
these words to this day that if you
don't find a way to accept your son
you're gonna lose him forever and it
still you know why you're crying though
it's because it matters it's important
it is it definitely is but there's still
a lot of guilt there yeah
you gotta forgive that yeah you
forgiving him absolutely he's forgiving
you forgive it and that's important
especially for this day in time like
right right now like what's happening in
society like it's so important for you
to say like look I didn't grow up around
this and this is okay like we have to
change we have to evolve because not
everybody is the same absolutely it is
very bold for a grown man to get up that
didn't grow up in that culture to get up
and wave that flag and say no this is
all right I like to also share that it
took me a long time to get to where I'm
at it took me years and years I went to
counseling and I recommend that for
anybody that's struggling with what what
I went through
yeah it's crucial that you get the help
and because just at the same time as
you're going I can't change me I don't
know how to change me he's going dude I
can't change me I don't know that this
is how I was this is how I was built
this is what I was taught and the thing
is it's totally okay to not understand
what's not okay stood not to try you
know and I think that's a really really
important message is that you know it
takes two to tango I didn't try with him
because I was struggling he didn't try
with me because he was struggling and so
we both just were clashing and it took
some time for us to get to the point
where it's like I want to have a
relationship with my dad he wanted have
a relationship with me yeah this is an
incredible uh-huh it's greca right yes
okay you're hiding I was like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so what is that entail what
does every do I mean honestly oh my gosh
so my mom I would say helps me with the
creative like creating product and
helping you with the labs and like you
know I test on her and I'm like mom I
need your home like she does everything
my dad also does everything they were in
the business side of it but like good
cop bad cop the creative don't have yes
people have them no people they say no
[Applause]
friends and family you want but this is
my favorite you even did your dad's
makeup right yes I did to see this
picture cuz I love it I'd love that you
were open to doing it oh my god okay
here's my face how hot did you look he
was everything exactly that's so good I
had the wrong lip color but I think
you're comfortable share your story
because I know you love daily makeup but
this story is a big part of it like I
think that's really important I think
for me the most important part is I have
a platform you know I have millions of
hours I watched me and I want people to
understand I didn't just get here
overnight you know it was a struggle it
was hard but you can get to the other
side it does become easier as time
progresses and I know I feel like when
you're in high school it feels like oh
my god this is it out to me forever you
know and it's not the case and I went
through hard times and me like dad both
went through really really hard times
together and now on the other end it's
like my dad works with me I I'm a CEO I
own lunar beauty and he worked with me
you know and my mom works with me and
inside so awesome and I want
know that it is going to get better for
you if you try why is it so important to
you Manny for me I think I just want to
show kids that are that are struggling
right now with parents that there's hope
that people can change if if given the
opportunity because there are so many
kids out there that are struggling and
going through dark times that don't have
that love and support that they that
they need at home and so for all the
parents out there there are struggling
your kids need you love has inspired
countless families including one from
his hometown of San Diego a 13 year old
ernesto says Manny's videos have made a
huge impact on his life he's here with
his mother Amber y'all come on out
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're shifting it's like musical chairs
um so you have something you want to say
to Manny
yeah I just wanted to say that you're a
really huge inspiration and I saw you at
a meet-and-greet and sadly I didn't have
enough time to like tell you how much
you meant to me but when I came out at
12 I always knew I was a little
different because I was into like makeup
and like girly things and I watched your
videos Tommy feel better in my skin
because I felt like you made me feel
better that I could be a boy makeup like
this is like why I do what I do you know
it's getting to hear these stories and
you know for me I'm just being myself
online and I would have never thought in
a million years I would have helped
people you know I'm hearing this it just
makes me feel so amazing and that's why
I do it you know and I'm so proud of you
and your browser snatched out well it
took me too I mean I wasn't comfortable
myself I was 21 so it's just it's so
awesome to see and I'm so proud of you
baby I think that what that means though
is we're progressing progressing as a
society it's where he feels comfortable
he's like yeah I'm 12 years old I know
I'm gay that's a really cool thing that
our society you feel comfortable and you
feel confident especially with this mama
bear right here who loves you either way
like what is this or mean to you um it
was hard being a single mom and when I
first had two boys you know his older
brother is rough-and-tumble and when jr.
came along it was different and we're
always close and buddy-buddy so I
thought maybe it's just a phase maybe
it's cuz he's always with me and then I
kind of realize okay this is here to
stay and I wasn't sure I embrace it what
do I do
I was wasn't scared that he was gay but
I was scared how people were gonna treat
my baby
so June and I started watching makeup
videos together and he would help us and
then he's like hey mom you know here's
Manny look Manny is just Manny
um cuz some people in makeup they are
different are they're very feminine but
Manny is very funny it was fun to watch
somebody that was like my baby yeah and
it was okay he's happy he's successful
his family loves him you know so and
then when jr. showed me the video of
Manny's dad it helped me kind of or at
least a little stress because you feel
kind of guilty you know what did I do is
this my fault
did I do something wrong and seeing
Manny's dad help me kind of just let
some of that go because you're not sure
how people are gonna think or act or
what they're gonna do and I felt maybe
like I'm not such a bad person I'm not a
bad mom because I didn't instantly go oh
my god this is great I mean I was happy
that he was happy being him but I was
still terrified and seeing Manny's dad
loved him through it struggle through it
and get through it made me feel like
okay maybe I did the right thing I did
it I can do this yeah
I love it yeah we're doing cats off to
you you have all my respect as a single
mother that is the hardest thing yeah my
kids are gonna be you know I'm saying
that's it's hard to do all on your own
my mama did that as well for a while so
I applaud you as well I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this